I'm wondering if you might be familiar with total triadols said to be vitamin E's cousin,
good for lowering cholesterol and triglycerides, if so would it be good for a breast cancer,
hormone positive patients. So, focal triadols are not vitamin E's cousin. Well, I actually pulled
up a little bit, but I saw this question. So, understand vitamin E in nature has really eight
parts to it. It has that outer tocopharol rings. And this is the, this is the organic
cup of makeup of a total triadol and tocopharol. So, vitamin E was like so many of the supplements,
so so many of the vitamins. When they were first discovered, there was only there was only a certain
level of microscopy. So, they could only see so much of the nutrient. So, the guy who discovered
vitamin C discovered the tocopharol. So, he called vitamin C tocopharol and then noticed there
were other tocopharol rings, actually four of them. So, that's the why they're named alpha, beta,
gamma, delta tocopharol. There's four tocopharol rings. So, legally, you could buy vitamin E,
you could go down to Walmart and buy vitamin E and it will say alpha tocopharol or alpha beta tocopharol
or mixed tocopharol. Okay, that's all legally a vitamin E. But that's not really what vitamin E is
in nature. So, if you eat food with vitamin E, I'll say you eat some salmon with vitamin E in it,
you're not getting just the tocopharol rings. So, later when microscopy as improved,
but the patent on vitamin E already came out, the definition of vitamin E already came out is
having these four tocopharol rings. So, legally, you could sell alpha tocopharol in the store and
you could call it vitamin E legally. But really, that's not really true. So, there's a lot of not
truths in vitamins. So, vitamin E later discover that it actually has an inner component
inside the tocopharol rings and there's four components of those and those are the total triadols.
So, there's alpha, beta, gamma, and delta tocopharol. So, you have these eight components of vitamin D.
Well, then they've been studied individually. So, alpha, the tocopharols can be very beneficial
for breast cancer. There's studies on the outer tocopharols for breast cancer and they've shown
the tocopharols, tocopharols and total triadols in high dose actually are pro-oxidative and they
can help kill cancers of all kinds. But many of the studies were done in breast cancer and the
high dose tocopharols have shown to help with breast cancer. But I'm convinced that it's really any of
the, if you did the whole food vitamin, it would be the high dose all the tocopharols and all the
total triadols. Now, the delta tocopharol triadol, that's the inner part delta tocopharol,
has been shown to be extremely beneficial for protection of cardiovascular disease. It's been
extremely beneficial to show healing of endothelial cells. Remember endothelial cells are the
epithelial cells that line our vascular system. Both both our arteries at our beta systems are
lined by a single layer of epithelial cells called your endothelial layer. So, those can be easily
damaged, though that endothelial layer can be easily damaged by a high called cysteine,
by heavy metals, by H. Pylori, we've talked about that before, by toxins at our environment and that
could lead to etchied and cholesterol buildup, cholesterol is not the bad guy. Remember, it's the
damage to the artery and cholesterol is actually trying to hatch that damaged endothelial cell.
So, also toxins get underneath the endothelial layer and can damage the smooth muscle layer,
which has a lot of receptors in it, ACE2 receptors, et cetera, that are affected by
nitric oxide synthase. We've had discussions about nitric oxide synthase. It's actually a nitric
oxide synthase that's called endothelial nitric hydroxide synthase or NOS3 that acts on smooth
muscles to help decrease blood pressure. And when you have damage to those receptors,
you can end up with a decrease in nitric oxide synthase and high blood pressure and the
delta-tocoltrinole can help heal that. So, the delta-tocoltrinole has been studied widely in helping with
cardiovascular events. There are a lot of other things too. At a correct dosage, which is a
relatively high dosage of vitamin E, either the I like to use the torque-offerals and the
total-treatals mix. That's what our A-pop E is. So, our A-pop E is torque-offerals and
total-treatals, especially the delta fraction of the total-treatal because it is so good for cancer
to help kill cancer cells, breast cancer, regardless of what type of cancer it is. And it's so
protective of the endothelial layer. And remember, cardiovascular disease is still the number one
cause of death in the United States. We don't like you surviving cancer than dropping
dental heart attack. So, taking the A-pop E is very beneficial. It's beneficial for anyone in the
dosage of taking one to three of those a day is very beneficial. So, that's the story. It's really not
the it's not the buzzing of vitamin E. Cocoa-treatals are the inner part of the whole food vitamin E
molecule and follow the nature. Though, it's off. That's why I don't like so many over-the-counter
supplements that you would buy in Walbert because they're going to give you the cheapest
form of vitamin E by legally collated vitamin E and they're only going to give you the alpha
clopperol, which really in high dose can be beneficial for breast cancer. But it's more beneficial for
the skin. It does nothing for cardiovascular. Cocoa-treatals do nothing for the cardiovascular system.
Benefact sadly, I don't know, it's fed too much time on this, but sadly they did a study a number
years ago, this is about 10-12 years ago, to try to disprove the benefits of vitamin E with cardiovascular
issues. Now, they don't necessarily do these studies bashing supplements anymore because so many
of the drug companies have bought out the supplement companies. Sorry, but it's very cynical, but that's
exactly the truth. So, now, they don't necessarily do these studies, but they purposely did this study
on whether vitamin E would be beneficial for heart disease and they used the
the the the to cough or all the alpha to cough or all and they said it was actually it was actually
detrimental to the heart. People just taking high dose to cough or all's had more heart issues
and then people that were taking it. Well, the problem is, is that if you take a fractional
supplement like just taking it to cough or all, you're going to actually you're going to have more
in your gut and you're going to take up absorption sites. Then if you were eating good food
with the whole food vitamin E with the Delta Tocotretals that are so supportive to the heart,
you're actually taking up absorption sites that you're not absorbing all the vitamin E from your food.
So, people that were on this study that were taking high dose alpha to cough or all were actually
blocking absorption of the Delta fraction of the Tocotretals. So, they weren't getting that protective
benefit from the Tocotretals from their diet. So, it was actually hurting their heart. Well, they
purposely did this and they got called out of this on this study. But of course, it went out and
seeing it and you know, all the new stations that take advantage of it is actually bad for your heart.
It's totally flawed study. This is how drug companies have worked in the games that they played for
years. Well, now they don't necessarily push those studies so much because they bought out,
you know, all these, you know, energetics and even good supplement companies are now owned by
drug companies. So, now they're friendly to nutrition or say, but that's the scale that we
have had to deal with all my life. So, such as life.